-His new album,
"Girls Night Out,"
is out October 21st.
Performing
"Don't Even Think About It"
with a little help from
The Roots,
please welcome Babyface
featuring Baby Tate!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Mm, yeah ♪
♪ Oh ♪
♪ I don't want wanna
see you when I wake up ♪
♪ No ♪
♪ But tonight, I want you
messin' up my makeup ♪
♪ 'Cause I got too many
problems with commitment ♪
♪ Oh ♪
♪ And I don't want you
to come and try to fix it ♪
♪ No ♪
♪ So this is only for tonight ♪
♪ And right now,
we can do whatever ♪
♪ Sit back
and just enjoy the ride ♪
♪ Don't even think about
forever ♪
♪ Don't even think about it ♪
-♪ Eyes closed,
let yourself go ♪
-♪ Don't even think about
forever ♪
♪ 'Cause I don't want to
see you when I wake up ♪
♪ Wake up ♪
♪ Hey ♪
♪ Baby, you better not
let me see you
when I roll over my pillow ♪
♪ You better not try to be
there in the morning,
I got to do ♪
♪ Better not keep on trying to
get to know me know me
like an interview ♪
♪ Better off finding
you somebody else,
there ain't no me and you ♪
♪ Tell your mama
I don't want to meet her ♪
♪ I know you probably
think you found a keeper ♪
♪ Let you in,
but you can't go no deeper ♪
♪ You just make sure you know ♪
-♪ This is only for tonight ♪
-♪ It's only for tonight ♪
-♪ And we can do whatever ♪
-♪ Sit back
and just enjoy the ride ♪
-♪ Just enjoy the ride ♪
-♪ Don't even think
about forever ♪
♪ Don't even,
don't even think about it ♪
♪ Don't even think about it ♪
-♪ Eyes closed,
let yourself go ♪
-♪ Don't even think about
forever ♪
♪ 'Cause I don't want it ♪
-♪ Listen ♪
-♪ You don't want to see
you when you wake up ♪
-♪ I don't want to see you
lay there ♪
-♪ 'Cause you don't
want to face another break-up ♪
-♪ I don't want to
face another ♪
-♪ I kiss you, gonna play it
till you wake up ♪
♪ And there's no one inside ♪
-♪ Oh, ohhhhh ♪
♪ Sit back
and just enjoy the ride ♪
♪ And don't even
think about it ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
-♪ Don't even think about it ♪
♪ Don't even think about
forever ♪
♪ No, no, no, no ♪
♪ No, ooh ♪
♪ No, ooh-hoo ♪
♪ No, ooh-ooh ♪
♪ Don't even think about it ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]